ladies and gentlemen I've been asked to  give the award for the best performance  by an actress in a supporting role or to  put it more succinctly the best picture  stealer the nominees are a miami badly  for room at the top  susan kona for imitation of life Juanita  more for imitation of life Thelma Ritter  for pillow-talk and Shelley Winters for  the Diary of Anne Frank and the winner  is miss Shelley Winters in the diary  you know it takes a lot of people to put  this in your hand for someone has to  write a dimensional roll in a very fine  motion picture and next somebody has to  get to the part then you have to have a  great director and then you have to be  nominated and voted so I would like to  thank the memory of that wonderful  little girl Miss Anne Frank who wrote  with such depth and perception about  human things I'd like to thank my  wonderful friend and creative agent mr.  herb Brenner and mr. George Stevens and  last but not least I thank you the  Academy  ah